Millennials good morning count good
morning sister amber I'm right so like
an hour and you're done yeah it's almost
as if the show made her sick
she's like averse to working she's the
girl with no job but I'm the sweet side
I get to host with my favorite counselor
counselor cinch counselor snitch
welcome counselor thanks for having me
how's it going it's going good I'm so
tired right now throat's a bit mucousy
so I kind of feel like I sound a little
bit like manly but you know it's just
rolling with it do what you need to do
just try not to cough oh no it's not
coffee it's just that my voice sounds
weird IRS's just me oh it's not coffee
is it just you uh yeah your voice sounds
fine to me you sound ready to host oh
that's great ready for the role of a
lifetime the role of a lifetime I've
never done it before actually have you
know you've done an interview with me
before you've done it post counselor
post counselor snitch before no but I
mean when we have guests oh I have not
really you good right so you're prepared
yes and actually I'm really know the
lost king song so we have the lost kings
with us here today
we'll be interviewing them later in the
show I'm so excited you're also a big
fan so am I so many songs that I was
just going through their roster right me
too on the way here I was like Alexa
play Lost Kings sorry guys and I really
thoroughly enjoyed getting ready this
morning we do we have them a little bit
later but there's a better version of
the chainsmokers that's what I think
they're single first niche I know I was
thinking that like maybe God made
Claudia sick so I could meet one of them
but they're definitely not Jewish so and
they're hopefully not watching this
right now oh yeah definitely not anyways
how has my favorite counselor been since
you've been on the show
I've been good same old like nothing new
school its final season final season Oh
give us just like the elevator pitch on
what you're dealing with
okay I'm dealing with the ton actually I
have a final Thursday a final Monday a
final Tuesday and then two papers due
Tuesday one of which is 12 pages Wow
yeah well we actually have a lot of
student toasters and I think we're
trying to recruit our student Osler is I
think that's a really solid fan base for
us so I'll talk about five miles
oh I'll indulge you first well this
doesn't happen off camera no it
but a question someone might ask or want
to know from you is really how do you
manage like school work being interned
snitch
being assistant snitch being counselors
makes you being body by snitch you
really wear so many hats how do you
manage your time well I will say that
school is on the bottom of that list but
I still get everything done you know
what it means I'm gonna miss assignments
and like I'm just like lacking they're
just like they could probably be better
but I still get them done and I still
hand them in on time and to me that is
just probably the most important I don't
really care about the quality of the
work because I find school to be stupid
these get degrees my friend geez get
degrees you just have to pass actually
no it's ease because from your major you
have to get a C or above fine okay let
me ask you a little bit of a personal
question
what's your GPA 3/4 Wow I know that's
really good that's a B D - no three to a
B is a three is a B all right it's like
a b-plus yeah I'm a very people s
student I feel like that would that that
makes sense for me I hate entering how
much I don't go I agree you're so b-plus
in every sense of the word
that's not except for hosting and being
a counselor I'm my look plus plus
counselor oh and your looks of course
I'm sorry plus I just I forgot what's
important to you here oh yeah also my
body is number one on your priority list
your looks and your and your bod
yeah and then number two would be the
grunge to our dirty jeans tour yes
numbers well because I have no choice
they're like I gotta get on the plane
right and you do really do work hard at
that and that's really like a little
career for you right now number three I
would say school comes before the toast
yeah because when I have a class I have
to go to I have to I gotta go and
technically we can manage without you
yeah like what data you have guests like
I am here but like on days when either
it's a regular show and like I can get
those hours to sleep in I will choose to
do that make sense no cos like there's
no point of me just sit what goes body
djt sleep school do not even body at
this point because I've been lacking on
that front just more so like concern
concern concern for the body in the face
okay well your body face you look great
thank you both
haier haier we were dying I know you
don't have time to watch it
watching the toast is down here for you
I actually do watch it sometimes like
when it's one of like I know that I
should watch yeah I mean yeah but I'll
only know that after the fact right
having been done well you've seen
Princess Diaries right yes I don't know
because you grew up in a different age
do the math no but I watched it with you
guys so we were crying over Lilly
Moscovitz
her friend oh yes she's insane anyways
welcome to the show
I'm so happy that you're here despite
you know the non-ideal circumstances of
our sister being very sick and I just
hope that she doesn't get anyone else
sick because I'm praying so grumpy so
not in the mood to be sick I mean I've
been pounding vitamin C because I just
can't get sick hmm very interesting yeah
you should get on that I should I need
to do 10 more black preventative
measures I know I'm taking I'm like
taking my vitamins because like I'm so
susceptible to getting sick that I do
I'm just not having it this time you are
we were actually having such an
interesting conversation before I've
never had strep knock on gilded wood um
but you've had it like 10 times I've had
it ten times my freshman year of college
I had it three times in a row like in
like a span of one month and my doctor
was like if you got it one more time we
have to take your tonsils out and
thankfully I didn't get it again but I
like I'm very susceptible to having it I
have I come oxacillin in my medicine
like I'm dial yeah at all points that
invalid track like the two things in my
backpack
right now that's so funny well that's so
switch of you and your counselor you're
always prepared right you got to take
care of those campers oh yeah as a
counselor how excited are you to get
back in the workforce at Camp DOS to
actually really excited I'm really
excited because of the weather like I
feel like it's gonna be so fun even
we're gonna be sweating our asses off
right cuz cam to us one the weather
couldn't have been worse if we tried and
it was still so much fun so like now
with ideal weather you know like Sun Sun
we didn't see the Sun we didn't see the
seven we didn't even see a like up one
cloud it was just like it looked like
London during the fog the whole time I
only know that from the crown but it was
very bleak I watched you know when
Churchill and the fog of London gets
killed by the fog so he started so does
something about
I don't know I think that was the crown
mm-hmm I think that's Churchill must a
must be yeah yeah there's a lot of
Churchill content out right now though
is there yeah there's that movie darkest
hour yes right okay fine so I'm only
been watching the crown but like he's
much slow
are you a Churchill fan I don't know I
honestly I know sounds so messed up like
I truly don't know what he did for the
world no he did I know he did good
things but I just don't know
he helped in World War two which is just
important for the Jews because it helped
end the Holocaust oh that's good that's
helpful I think it's really helpful for
us okay are you ready for the fast five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toes yes because I actually
don't know went on yesterday in the
world well the good news for you not
that much happened so the stories are a
little thin but they're thin stories on
wider topics that I just want to get the
young pulse on okay because you are you
know the the freshest youngest thing on
the street right Claudie and I are very
old so I just want to get your opinion
on the things that are going on okay
first of all Pete Davidson is quote
casually dating after your ariana grande
split
Pete Davidson is moving on the SNL star
has been dating since keen ariana grande
called off their engagement quote he's
been going on dates but it's casual a
source said he's been trying to move on
and live a more private life David
Davidson was spotted out to dinner with
a mystery woman at carbone on Monday
evening but we've learned it wasn't
anything serious he did however join an
exclusive dating app in the hopes of
finding love I wonder which one
definitely
right yeah quote the set it up actors
for a back into the D and we're all
comes nearly two months after he and
grande split while Davidson is back on
the scene Grande denied rumors that
she's back together with ex-boyfriend
Ricki Alvarez whom she mentioned and
thank you next that was a rumor because
she liked coming something like nice on
his picture and so people just assume
they're dating like you know if she ever
dated him again like she has made me
like such a Stan if she ever did that
like I'm done
I'd like I never supported that
relationship said someone else and her
name is Ari
oh yeah and she's so good with that so
good with that I'm so good with that
just coming out the song tomorrow okay
so I really brought this story up
because I just want to get you know the
teenage pulse not some I'm Pete Davidson
I'm Pete Davidson on Ariana Grande like
what are your thoughts on Pete Davidson
I know our he's a friend of yours so you
wouldn't do this for her but
say you know hypothetically would you go
out with him like do you think he's a
cutie here's a picture of him I honestly
wouldn't go out like do you get the
appeal I'd I kind of I see the appeal in
the sense of like for ariana grande or
like just for people to like say it but
like personally like I couldn't do you
want me like I don't see it for myself
but I see it for other people that make
sense yes that does make sense yeah no
he kind of like scares me but like I
feel bad for him like I feel really bad
for him he got the short end of the
stick on this one he did but he also got
like even a stick by going out with her
I know but like it's wasn't worth it
I was the high worth the pain I think it
was cuz he was so obsessed with her I
remember when he would just like post
pictures of her and be like my fiance is
like the hottest woman in the world
which makes me even sadder because then
he would always say on interviews he'd
be like like when we break up cuz I can
do she good to be true but she's just so
sad so that yeah like I don't know so
who's your celebrity crush Wow
older young oh my god right I have an
affinity you have an issue I have an
issue I like young please okay um wow I
never really think about that or you
know age appropriate age appropriate no
no like and someone who's by the way not
married not a father and potentially a
grandfather I don't think any of them
are grandfathers um you never know oh so
on the spot like I need a Shawn Mendes
with blue eyes oh you need to someone
with blue eyes I love blue eyes - Zac
Efron have blue eyes he's old yeah he is
kind of old he's looks like nice 35 yeah
yeah out past him
yeah what about Justin Bieber no way
okay
who we'd rather go out with Justin
Bieber Pete Davidson I don't know
because like technically Justin Bieber
cuz he's like more famous but like he
scares the [ __ ] out of me like I don't
know what he would do to me yeah after
all the blinds like I'm good that's
maybe this Pete Davidson be a little bit
uncomfortable but like I'm sure things
would go smoothly and I carbone I've
never been but I haven't one delicious
so a free meal at carbone I'm assuming
he picks up the tab but I don't know
maybe that that's an omen he's not as
good as you would well he got the ring
back so maybe he sold it and now he's
and now he's happy for dinner yep with
that
money because he didn't repay with re I
want to go to car boat and that's not my
list of Italian spot said I said that
for your birthday but I got ignored um
no but like I still want to go there
maybe like after I don't know let's
think maybe the next G I know a little
Carbone how do you end a ring I was
gonna say like you can't really like go
out after a car bonemeal no but a Sunday
night GNO where we just serve our faces
with pasta sounds so fun so what did you
think of gino oh my god it was so fun
like truly so much fun I don't know why
I left early which I didn't think it was
early he was like 2:45 and I was just
like oh my god like I'm really tired
once I got that tired wave hit me like I
had to go home right so I was like and
like no one was quite there yeah and I
felt like everyone probably just leave
in like 30 but I was like I'll just go
home and like whatever then I woke up
and I had these text at like 4:45 like
home love you but I don't like what the
hell did I miss so I like called you
guys I was like what happened like I
can't I'm never the first one to leave
but I was just tired and I was having
crazy FOMO I didn't really miss that
much just like you continuation of the
fun right it's but I got the gist I got
the gist of the fun
but yeah it was really fun and I was so
hungover the next day like my head it's
just getting it really gets worse ii
turned 21 that's so sad for me you know
i didn't get so bad until i turn in 23
24 but like my hangovers are just having
another level and like my new thing is
that i throw up in the next day oh
that's when it's bad what about when you
throw up the next evening that's never
happened to me it's usually when i just
wake up can you imagine that very sad
but i feel like you don't ever throw up
ah no sometimes they do I mean if it's
the next day throw up like I'm in really
bad shape but sometimes I feel like
throwing up will only make things worse
so I try to keep it down I always think
that throwing up will make me better
even sometimes we will but sometimes it
won't
I don't know anyways moving on to our
next story which is just a portal
through which we can talk about
Riverdale Mark Consuelos and his
Riverdale family star on Kelly Ripa's
best holiday card yet did you see this
yes so Kelly the Consuelos family
holiday card this year is a photo of
Hyrum Hermione and Veronica I guess they
got really lazy and also a little
thirsty and this is their holiday card
and I'm really so here for it even
though I don't really keep up with the
Consuelos is I don't keep up with the
Consuelos is either but I saw it and I
didn't think it was real
I thought it was like the lodges
Christmas card like from Riverdale cuz I
don't know I just thought so um it's
funny but like Kelly Ripa is just like
thirsting for the Riverdale of it all
and it's like you know she's gonna be on
it I know which is just like this season
like every show has a bad season like
Gossip Girl it had a bunch I'm about to
enter one on Heart of Dixie it's just
something you have to deal with we are
in one right now like they make these
writing decisions in the writing room
they think it's gonna go over well and
it just doesn't like in Friday Night
Lights the murder in season two like
well that's for the gargoyles like so
I'm gonna push through but I'm not happy
yeah so I kind of have come to terms I'm
now caught up on Riverdale and watch
last night it's no no it's last name was
Tuesday is it on Tuesdays today's
Wednesday today's Wednesday so it's time
tonight okay so it's on tonight
so when Riverdale first started it was
just like everything we ever needed in
life and more right and I feel as though
especially with like Sabrina the Teenage
Witch it's like the teens really do like
this like sci-fi horror stuff and so I'm
not going to tell them what the show
should be about because they're clearly
doing something right and I think people
don't like it right now really I look at
Twitter like often it's just the
Riverdale hashtag I like people are like
WTF well I'm at least interested like
what in the hell is going on like what
is what is it right but you know what I
also don't know don't understand is how
Betty's like missing and nobody seems to
care like what about I know that Jughead
and Archie are like away but she's not
answering him so shouldn't he be
concerned yes but then he literally said
that Kevin Kevin and Veronica are there
where is she yeah I agree with that well
apparently at tonight Veronica and
Sheryl maybe go looking for Betty
but Jughead addressed it when he said
Betty took down a serial killer last
year like Archie you can't ever like
stay out of prison or trouble so that's
why he's like no I already knows that
Betty can whatever she's going through
and I'm sure she he knows that she's
dealing with something that she can
handle herself right by the way
liliane : now so our Academy and melt
Charles you know and also now I'm
feeling like Veronica and Reggie I said
that to you I
that to you the last time that we were
here I was like because their writer
Ross just like listens to what other
people say and because they are dating
in real life they're going to date on
the show and you know I'm going to ups
and I'm shipping it I ship it to
honestly they have night together I ship
Veronica and Archie so much like they
are endgame you think they are my
favorite Riverdale not that there's so
many Riverdale couples but like I mean
you know I can't deal with Betty and
Jughead and they're like [ __ ] Nancy
Drew syndrome okay but for onigen Artie
like I love that they're so ride-or-die
and like Hiram needs to just like turn
all of his anger towards Archie and to
like embrace for Archie because they can
really work well together and what
Archie did to him like he did so much
for him just he went against him once I
back off why do you need to kill him no
he's so not tie room it's just no he not
at it it's like not even like believable
do you know what I mean no but then when
they went to the other town and then it
all came back to the prison it became
believable what he's just a psycho like
he's a psycho like it's the prison it's
the drugs like he's got this whole
county on rap yeah yeah that's true
I mean I don't know it's rough one for
me I think but I'm just enjoying it like
I'm just interested to see the flashback
episode though was really great like I
was dying for it you were yeah oh wait
were you not um I don't know oh my god I
thought I thought it was a great
flashback episode but I just personally
don't love a flashback episode like I
remember when they did that on Gossip
Girl and it was so annoying I don't
remember that you don't it was like but
you know what I've been realizing aside
from Riverdale all the shows that we
love like over time are all Josh
Schwartz and Stephanie Savage dynasty
Gossip Girl The OC Heart of Dixie all of
it they do everything they are the
people that we used to follow them
whenever they put their names on I'm in
they do the team shows they do the team
shows and they do them right I mean
dynasty is just I haven't watched last
week's but like dynasty is just so good
and it's like you know what I'm
realizing the more TV that I watch it's
like it's all about the writers uh-huh
and it's like I feel like now it's so
hard for people to like be good at it
like they just can't come up with a
night nice plot twist but they
can like dynasty is just taking me left
right and center yeah um I heard some
like spoilers me too
oh where you oh yeah yeah but um I
remember some but not all excels really
drunk and I was trying to remember so
we'll talk we'll go over them after if
you're not watching dynasty yet like get
caught up start watching it's the
greatest show that's on right now that
it's the 2018 Gossip Girl and speaking
of Gossip Girl Netflix is Gossip Girls
summary is so shady did you see this no
okay so I'm Netflix when you go to
Gossip Girl and you look at the
description the description says rich
unreasonably attractive private school
students do horrible scandalous things
to each other repeatedly oh my god why
isn't that so crazy that's like the
weirdest thing ever like someone at
Netflix just mad dad and like just snuck
it in and it's hilarious and also true
but then they also should have said that
Serena van der Woodsen while you think
might be like the protagonist is
actually the worst character are very
similar to a Carrie Bradshaw
Wow you're gonna make that's your thesis
that's my thesis I I hate Serena van der
Woodsen like okay like I don't hate her
I definitely think she makes poor
decisions but I'm coming to learn that
like everybody makes poor decisions on
all shows that I like heart of sexy but
I didn't make poor decisions that's true
and I'd wait are you okay I saw your
story last night about Heart of Dixie
Dixie and it's unclear if you're okay
not okay because like I hate when people
do stupid things for no reason when
things are going great
why sabotage them you mean like Marissa
Cooper dying well that was just
different
but um that was her wanting to get off
the show no that's different I'm just
talking about the characters I don't
know man it was just like everything was
going so smooth and then it just hit a
it hit a wall and then I cried I'm
starting to learn that I could cry from
anything look I see these 15-second
snippets on my Instagram like I cry Wow
well I just want you to know every time
you post a picture of you crying you
screenshot I scream I got it now I'm
starting a folder because they're
literally so sad like nothing will be
sadder than one ring a James side right
and then way to ruin it oh sorry they
don't know what you chose over yeah or
then you watch that movie that you made
me watch nice but you understood yeah
you guys should really watch this movie
it's like so heartbreaking but
it's nice it's nice it's called not
Cinderella's type and cry but they're
not sad because it's not like I'm crying
about personal issues it's like I'm
crying about someone who's a fake
person's problems that's true but maybe
it just triggers something in you like a
very sadness no no no I just like I get
invested yeah and then bad things happen
and I cry so but you're still enjoying
Hart of Dixie yes but now it's like now
that it's not going the way that I
wanted to I'm not gonna be like
thirsting to watch at any second that I
can do you know what I mean it's like
wow studying for finals it's like oh my
god I really want to be watching her
Dixie but now that it's in a place that
I'm upset about I'll take my sweet time
your sweet time also I do need to issue
a correction Blair didn't make one
horrible choice by dating dan like oh
and Louie no but like she was a princess
I can understand why she did I get it
but like come on and she wouldn't know
he was so crazy until like literally
right after they got married but that
was like the weird season for Gossip
Girl when Blair and Dan we're like two
you know the weird season for Gossip
Girl was like the ivy Juliet of it all
that was so weird that was those things
other words you should honestly just
skip them ivy
no but it's silly cute and good in New
York and fashion and enjoyable that's
also any what's-her-face went to NYU
Blair that was also she that was also so
real so real because that's what happens
to me I'm a loser at school are you
excited to graduate I am really excited
to do things more excited you or me
I don't know you're pretty up there I'm
planning the biggest party of all time
yeah we are planning the biggest
graduation party of all time it's gonna
be in the Guinness Book of World Records
yes for the biggest celebration of
someone graduating cuz like finally
finally it's been holding you back what
if I told you that I wanted to go to
grad school
I don't but imagine I don't know when I
would I literally don't know what I
would do no I would be - truly no
interest I would be heartbroken you
would break my heart
freaking a sister's heart just something
to think about okay next story speaking
of Netflix wow this is really Netflix
heavy episode not sponsored but it could
be Selina Kenton I can never
so the Selina scripted series headed to
net
I can never pronounce her last name and
I'm not gonna insult her by trying
Netflix has ordered a scripted series
based on the life of Tejano music star
Selena not Gomez TJ TJ series is
described as a coming-of-age story
following Selena as her dreams come true
and all the heart-wrenching and
life-changing choices she and her family
have to make as they navigate success
family and music quote Selena will
always have a lasting place in music
history and we and we feel great
responsibility to do justice to her
memory said Selena's sister with this
series viewers will finally get the full
history of Selena our family and the
impact she has had on all of our lives
we are excited to partner with compen
REO and netflix to get bands never
foreseen glimpse at our story and
highlight why Selena will mean a legend
for generations to come
I'm so excited for this me too I
actually saw the movie that I think is
just called Selena
yeah with JLo yeah with JLo and I just I
didn't really know anything about her
because I think before my time but like
it was so good and I'm actually really
gonna watch it and Netflix has been
churning out some great freakin content
lately Miam content yeah and also aren't
they doing custom oh yes I can't wait to
watch that yesterday oh my god I can't
wait to watch it but I'm a little
worried but you know I will keep myself
open minded that all of the content that
they have is what we already saw in
social media you know like everyone who
got their posting yeah but maybe they'll
go back but like a little more in-depth
of the people who organized it what it
says about our society etc probably well
but I didn't really see that much like
it's like I saw people like being like
stranded but like I needed more and I
feel like now I'm gonna have more cheese
sandwiches oh my god those salads that
was so that's the craziest car do you
imagine if that were us no no I can't
like what would I do you think that's
something I take great pride in it's
like I didn't go to fire fest but we
would never really travel that far for a
festival the farthest will go is
stagecoach I know I'm so excited for
station yeah we're going yeah we're
going of course we're going I mean I
want to of course put in my letter um so
yes Netflix is very much in tune I'm
looking for it I love like there's
nothing better than a great documentary
I agree I could what are some of your
favorites documentaries you saw three
identical stranger
yeah so that's it yeah that isn't that's
that was that shook me um I'm trying to
think my favorite documentaries like I
don't really know that what what is a
documentary that when I watch it yeah
cuz it tells like a good story
have you seen queen of Versailles know
about that house that family in Florida
who's building the biggest house in
America modeled after Versailles and it
was filmed in 2008 and as they're
filming this documentary about them
building the biggest house like the
recession happens and they like lost all
their money and they had to stop
building the house and it's like this
documentary took like a crazy turn they
were just really filming them making it
like about now let's do that money again
or nom unclear wow that's so sad so is
the house still like just chill in there
it's not Netflix yeah time Netflix or
it's been there for a long time I got
there I also just watch the American
meme oh yeah you did was good it was
good I would recommend MIT I like it
gotta get on my jacket documentary game
yeah and they're so informative I think
like I literally my whole range of
conversation topics has changed since I
saw three identical strangers right no
sometimes you watch something that it's
like you just can't stop talking about
and a way to work it into every
conversation I get like that like when I
even when I watch TV shows like all my
friends I always talk to them now about
Heart of Dixie half of them are watching
so that's great but like even see like
it's like or I was talking I was been
telling my friends like any one of my
friends who would face I may be like hey
you're about to show red oak so I really
think you'd like it
I was gonna ask you up even watching red
oaks well I watched the first season and
a couple of episodes of the second
season with Claudia on Sunday and then
I've just been going back to Heart of
Dixie but I'm gonna finish it at some
point I just haven't gotten there are
you excited for the country club life oh
oh my god I'm so excited for the country
club life like there's just no better
life in the country club like when I go
with my friend who's still joint it's a
country club like those barbecues like
they just can't be beat man like they
can't be beat and like now that we drink
it's gonna be so different we've never
even been to the bar they're right all
we did we went to like the cookie bar
which I will still be a nothing bar oh
my god all the dance born this tan floor
I wonder if they have like adults-only
parties oh for sure I mean yeah cuz my
guy needs to go all the time yeah and
then we were home just like being steamy
we probably literally didn't even talk
to each other but yes we did we were
always having fun time were we
yeah
I don't remember what it was like when
we were yeah cuz you were so young so
you don't remember
that's true but we were always having I
just remember moving out into the
library when caught it pissed me off
yeah you were you were sad when people
would come to the hallway to get their
own rooms
yeah I really moved into the hallway and
then people would walk through the hall
and she'd get out of my face I didn't
need it to walk through there to go to
their own room so psycho so psycho can
wait to go back to those memories no but
you see dumpling yet no but it's on my
list and we have to go see Shh clueless
oh yeah how when why I don't know but we
had to figure it out if anyone from the
clueless team is watching we would go
and we would promote it yeah assuming
it's Kevin um I also wanted to ask you
I'm sure this is gonna be the last time
you're hosting with me before the new
year but what are your new year's
resolutions
oh they're usually the same every year
lose weight find a man is pretty much it
nothing you want to change nothing you
want to learn I'm gonna learn how to
drive do you want to join oh I gotta get
my permit
that'll be my Red Sox you two we got a
new tire I can't look I can't learn how
to drive without a permit right right
because you need to [ __ ] that really why
it'll take five no it was like for me no
because getting a permanent like a whole
thing in itself I have to study for the
test I should go to the DMV and like put
myself through that I had to take a
picture like and then just to start the
endeavour to get my license I really
like don't think it's like I'll try I'll
do it with you it's like I think we
should do together and we'll get lessons
together that I helped but like I just
don't think that like this girl right
here can drive a way for living the
country club life I got it but like I
went behind the wheel one time and I
freaked it freaked out like it is just
not but I'm that's what happens when you
as you get older you get more scared I
couldn't agree more
because you're more aware of your own
mortality and the mortality of others
yeah like I will kill someone but when
you're 15 you're like I'm driving get
out of my way [ __ ]
clear the roads clear the roads snitch
on the loose I'll do that with you okay
and then my other one is to learn how to
cook something you should also do with
me let me find a man to cook for first
no but I'm cooking for myself so that I
can like not have to order everything
and then it's something's ordered our
gross
you know gross like eggs yeah but eggs
do you know how to make I know make eggs
yes but I could like what about a
frittata
I love a 4-top do you love a frittata
yeah can we see Morning Glory yeah yeah
I have like kid don't remember what
you're referring to but I've seen it
yeah if you've seen it you know okay
fifth and final story a little business
we touched on this a few weeks ago but
the New York Times is reporting the
Chinese hackers are behind the massive
Marriott breach a massive data breach at
a Marriott hotel chain has been traced
to Chinese hackers working for the
Ministry of State Security the country's
civilian spy agency according to the New
York Times the hack exposed data from
approximately 500 million Marriott and
Starwood Hotel customers it also
included health insurers and the
security clearance files of millions
more Americans according to two people
briefed on the investigation The Times
report in what do they want with that
information
like it's just really sensitive
information and this is a hotel chain so
it has people's obviously their credit
card information their passport
information all this stuff personally
I'm not a hotel
Starwood member janii there I'm just
getting my like credit card points in
check I'm doing one thing at a time but
that's really crazy I think it's the
biggest data breach in history so far in
history yeah the bottom I really hear
about it um
I don't know if this is something that
you and your friends talked about I
don't know but like I just feel like I'm
pretty well versed like it just didn't
really I only heard about it at first
about at the points guy Awards yeah that
was funny
but that's crazy so like what do you do
now how do you get that info back you
can't you can't like you just pray so
who's gonna get fired
I don't know IT guys IT yeah sad that's
why I wasn't a computer science major I
was gonna get fired
The Times also cited for unnamed US
officials who said there could be
indictments against Chinese hackers for
working for the intelligence services
and the military
it said the Trump administration also
plans to declassify intelligence reports
to reveal Chinese hacking efforts dating
to at least 2014 the report comes amid
growing tensions between the US and
China so it's like like a blackmail huh
you know like there's like it's crazy
it's just like the war on Cristiano the
war on personal information very scary
that's really scary stuff all these
hacks are so crazy it's like this isn't
even but I think that we always hear
about hacks and then like we don't
really hear about the repercussions of
like what they did with said information
um there are some yes you do like for
example when Ashley Madison was hacked
oh yeah but I'm talking about when I say
Sony was hacked and all their emails
were leaked remember that yes you okay
you remember this the story was I don't
even know if I remember actually Madison
that when Sony was releasing the dictate
of oh yeah what happened because the
dictator no the dictators with um Sacha
Baron Cohen injure the one about Kim
jong-un yet oh the dictator dot you're
right
the interview I was saying that right
and then it's just I didn't North Korea
was so against it they hacked all of
Sony's emails and then they started
publishing them and it was like really
crazy stuff about like pay disparities
all these things and it was really bad
for them Wow all because of that movie
which by the way is hilarious it's very
I'm not Simon oh yeah yeah that was
really a crazy time crazy time and like
they never made it to theaters it did in
no I don't think it said we watch it was
just like on demand I don't even want to
talk about it that's how scary that is
but yes so anyways hacks do you have
effects but like it's all this credit
card information is really like that
wouldn't become like a news yeah we know
emails are juicy and stuff like that but
if you have like someone's credit card
number like then you're a stalker right
they might just sell it on the dark web
and then you get um fraud and all that
jazz so just a lot of work for the
credit card companies yes sad scary
stuff so if you are Marriott Starwood
member just make sure all your stuff is
in check it's like from conventions up a
Shopaholic I didn't go to outdoor world
so anyways teaches before we bring out
the Lost Kings is there and now five
stories that was five stories Wow five
easy story
that's what happens on a thing day and
also I just wanted to um you know get a
chance to really talk to you get to know
the woman behind the counselor is there
anything you want to promote or say or
you know get out there take your hip the
pique yet no day today oh that forty
nine point one K I need to get about
nine hundred followers
there's over fifteen hundred people
watching right now lives hopefully most
of you would follow me that'd be great
but if you don't nine hundred of you
please follow me so I can get to fifty K
very exciting thank you so much for
filling in being a grace a great sister
a great professional you're so
professional so professional and then
we're gonna talk to the lost kings I'm
really so excited if you have questions
for them write them on the YouTube
stream or on our Instagram post we will
get them all to them maybe they'll sing
us a little ditty no but they do like
the the beats and stuff so they actually
need a vocalist
it's a shame Claudia um I guess we'll
have to step in oh god okay I am taking
voice lessons oh also I just wanna get
your opinion on one more thing because
we announced the Grammy nominations
that's me oh my god and I'm not very
happy about it whatsoever like okay
Taylor that's just one thing like this
is her tenth I don't know this is her
tenth what I don't understand is last
year when Taylor didn't even put out an
album she was nominated for two Grammys
for like I don't know a better man and
something I was like random things right
she puts out a her best-selling most I
would say most amazing album great album
speak now I was better anyway and she
gets nothing at one sorry pop vocal is
that even a real group I thought you
were gonna be upset about create a
showman versus star is born well here's
the thing wasn't greatest showman for
last year's Grammys that's um I don't
think so no no no no you're wrong
because but it's nominated this year so
it couldn't been last year hmm I didn't
know I was supposed to be upset I
thought it was just like their and
shallow is nominated four times for song
of the year when like honestly come on
guys
but like this is no it isn't right this
is what makes me so mad about stars born
is that while it was a fantastic movie
between the two musicals movies that
came out stars morning greatest showmen
gradation when it's just so much better
and it's not getting accolades it
deserves and it's like I'm sure stars
stars born he's gonna get nominated for
an Oscar for this for that it's like
great good for you but like the fact
that you guys are all sleeping on
greatest showmen it's so [ __ ] up do
you know like almost a year ago today we
saw a greatest showman for the first
time or I think on April 19 we're coming
up on the one-year anniversary's and our
lives changed forever we went to an
advanced screening I was in the middle
of finals and I didn't give a flying
thanks to Lee a guy yes and I AG we went
and our lives were changed I just
remember me and you sitting there after
moving you're like what we were like
that was the greatest thing I've ever
that was the greatest show anyways this
is actually the greatest show the
greatest live show we will be back in a
few minutes with the Lost Kings stay
tuned Thank You speeches welcome
you
welcome back everyone we are here with
the lost king thank you so much for
joining us thank you very much we're
such big fans of your work actually big
fans of your work Thank You New York
how's it going we saw you went out last
night yeah we were a lead pretty good
this morning we like we did responsible
party and last thing they show is very
hangover friendly like the chairs are
comfortable you can sort of sausage it's
not too early also like you don't have
to wake up that early yeah yeah yeah
exactly the only thing is the cold that
that makes it a little worse yeah that
makes it yeah it's nice to get like a
taste of the cold and then go back so we
are actually very big fans of all of
your songs we were listening this
morning just talking about like the
whole your whole catalogue is so
impressive you worked with so many
really amazing artists um a personal
favorite of mine is phone down like
Emily Warren it's just like such a cutie
yeah yeah she's great um so this that
song was really successful and I think
it really spoke to a lot of people
because we are really addicted to our
phones so like writing that song what
was that process like and I mean I'm
sure inspiration was easy to find
um but yeah tell us about that so Emily
actually sent us the idea she had the
phone down idea and it's obviously like
resonated right away with us obviously
it's a universal concept with our
generation right now so we like you know
the challenge was flipping because it
was very slow like when she sent us her
original idea and so we had to find a
way to flip it to make sense for what it
is we do as artists and to give it like
energy you know it's very like low
energy very baladi like and it was just
really soft so we had to find a way and
it took us like five months till I get
it where we wanted it to be yeah it took
a while and like we went back and forth
we did a bunch of different versions and
but she was like great through the whole
process I mean like we didn't want
anybody else to sing it she was so good
on it but yeah it really resonated with
us and it was a great like
it's like a restart for us because we
had been doing remixes and we had a few
originals but this was like you know
look this is what we feel right now with
like how we interact with our friends
our you know yeah everybody it's just
like everybody we played it for we're
just like oh this is such a message that
needs to be out there so it was great
and Emily was like amazing so it was it
was a process but we were happy that it
finally like it made its way out and
made its way out into the world and
people love it so it's cool you also
collaborated with Tinashe Sabrina
carpenter we love how do you guys choose
who you want to work with we like you
know we will listen to a ton of music so
we just kind of like make a list of like
artists that we love and think we could
do something cool with and then when we
have the record for them like we reach
out like or have our label reach out or
manager and kind of just have this like
running order of like people that we
want to work with and Sabrina
Tinashe Ally Brooke from fifth harmony
they were all like at the top of the
list of like people that we love very
we're always fans of their voices like
the fans first and that's like you know
we love their voices always like we're
trying to you know it's just all about
having the right song and if they love
the song too you know but we're always
like listening to you know I mean we
love doing female records and we love
like we have so many females that we
look up to like their voice and how they
do things and it's it means a lot to get
them on our songs you know you saw for
sure so who's someone that you haven't
worked with yet that's on your list or
that you have one coming out with that
you want to spoil yeah they'd I'd say so
one that we have coming out we have a
record with Wiz Khalifa and social house
yeah that's crazy
yeah yeah we love the work that they've
done with Ariana and like thank you yeah
so we're super excited about that
yeah Wiz and then we have Lauren crayon
a song as well oh my god you're speaking
our lady way yeah we love
I thought he was gonna say that's your
dream like saw literally like it
couldn't be better
yeah yeah she yeah we're we're shooting
video next week for the song we're super
excited to be the first time that we
meet her because we sent her the song
she cut it and yes she was great she
sounds amazing on the song she had a
really really really good job so we're
excited so exciting so when you have an
idea first on you write the song you you
pitch it to the artist that you like how
long does that whole process take it
takes a while thanks a lot yeah we this
song that she's singing on in particular
was like kind of a crazy nightmare
session like my car broke down before
the session which was like it was such a
weird scenario so when we got this
session we were already like I was like
walk up like the hill yeah it was just
like 100 degree weather we're sweating I
was like Oh high anxiety for this
session yeah so we wrote it with this
girl - Lacey who we wrote first love
with she's absolutely amazing and this
other guy Michael [ __ ] and we did a
session and and so we were just like I
was rattled before we got in there and
then we we all wrote this this song it's
called anti everything and it's kind of
just like this you know it speaks for
itself second anthem yeah yeah yeah so
we we wrote the song and then I produced
the music and it took a while like it
took me like a month or so to produce
the music and that's gotta go through a
bunch of people and then it's like
alright now we find the list of people
that want to sing it yeah and Lauren was
at that top list
we were like you know I want Lauren to
say I like what she had put out you know
she doesn't have that much music not yet
but I like the first song that she put
out and then she just put out a note
which is great it's a really good and so
choose at the top of the list for the
song so yo I want her to cut this and
she cuz she did amazing job yeah that is
so so proud of her yeah yeah but it's
like takes months it's like you know
it's like writing a song and producing a
song and then
like going through finding the right
teacher and seeing if they want to
actually do it or not and she was down
from from the job that's like the middle
when like dad said like 11 and we yeah
it's a such a process with that song
especially there's like a certain
emotion to it and like capturing the
emotion that was originally there was
such a hard thing to do and Lauren was
able to do it but that was a process of
like you know just like getting to them
yeah because you gotta have somebody
that embodies that like the lyric when
when the song does come out and you hear
it it's like you have to embody that you
have that body that image too you can't
just like that's like the hard thing is
finding somebody that makes sense for it
that is gonna embody those lyrics that
isn't just gonna sound good it's like
you got to sound good you got to embody
the lyrics so it doesn't come off
knowing like peoples like personalized
like don't match up like what they're
singing about is wrote this or this
isn't very yeah yeah for like a 30 year
old not feel like an 8 year old
I think they made it as age-appropriate
as possible like it was clearly a
florida georgia line song that didn't
make the cut right and then they took
out some lyrics just were like my family
but Stelling not the original no you
guys also remix a lot of songs how do
you choose which songs you want to remix
like what about it speaks to you like
can you just remix whatever you want or
you have to work with that artist like
how does that ya know it's like we
haven't done a remix it up in a little
while and it's for a reason we wanted to
like establish you know we like doing
what we like what we want to do we
really feel like there's no rules in
what we want like what we do as
electronic producers we just want to
make the best music that we can no
matter what style it is no matter what
genre it is but like for remixes it's
like that's when we first were doing
remixes it was really just about how can
we take like a record that people
wouldn't expect us to flip and flip it
like into what we want to do and kind of
show it was like kind of a like showcase
on what we could do as producers before
we show people what how we can write our
own songs and kind of give people like
you know give them anticipation for what
what we would put out as like original
music but um but yet now it's like we're
super choosy like yeah it's got to be a
song that I like listen to on repeat
that I'm like you know I'm like yo this
is like I Jam the song all the time and
now it's like a lot I mean I listen to a
lot of rap music and I would love to
premix rap music more but they don't
ever give out their stems which is super
frustrating they never give out their
vocals right cuz I'm sure it's also a
card with just like the legal but I'm
sure it also makes you be more creative
yeah yeah like when we first started we
were just like bootleg everything like
you know download acapellas and put
stuff out but yeah we don't do it as
much because like SoundCloud will like
take down your remix yes put it on so
it's so remixes are just harder to do
yeah that like they may not really yeah
they made it really hard for us to like
want to do it it has to go through all
the legal processes before galti is
getting in everyone's way luckily we
take some viewer questions for you guys
um who are some of the nicest or rudest
celebrities or bands that you've played
with or met oh you can think nice is
because no one really ever wants to
throw shade on this units a shade
throwing dude or like you can do like a
blind item will speak the truth yeah
like I mean all the people that we've
worked with have been awesome yeah
Sabrina and Hallie like Ally's one of
the nicest people yeah that we've ever
met just in anything I feel like even if
we weren't working together like she
makes everyone feel like family so she's
always been great like we've become
friends with like a lot of like some
football players so like Christian
McCaffrey is like also one of the nicest
he's like he's super nice
he's like he's so nice he came out to
one of our shows other day and brought
us jerseys and all that he's a good dude
yeah cool what has been your favorite
city to play mine is Miami I would say I
like playing in New York like when we're
here because our whole team's here so
it's like and with friends and family so
it's like I'm a big coming home party
every time I hear where are you guys
from originally I'm from Baltimore and
I'm from Boston oh very cool we're the
number one podcast in Massachusetts so
what happens go into what factors go
into you guys deciding what festivals
and performances outside of touring that
you want to do right now it's pretty
much we just like want to do everything
and anything that we can get on like I
don't mean to be general but like it's
really we're just trying to do whatever
we can and especially this year we're
doing our first tour like first venue
tour so we're like getting out at
nightclubs and getting into more venue
so we can have more fans that can't come
to nightclubs or maybe under 21 so yeah
but festivals I mean like you know we
did alter last year we want to do that
we're think we're gonna do that again
this year and that's like that's amazing
it's like before alter they do like
Miami Music Week and we used to go to
Miami Music Week like but never really
get to experience ultra and so to
finally do ultra last year was like
amazing I was like yeah oh my god this
is this is a big one yeah yeah like the
first Huntly because we don't get
nervous either and that was like the
first time I was like weeks leading up
to it I'm like what are some of your
pre-show rituals drinking lots of
tequila he's gonna take you guys
straight you pack you like you have to
drink you're like yeah I pick him shoes
though you do so many shows you gotta
like pick and choose good nights
I'm very I like to be very calm
personally like I like to be there's a
lot always a lot going on I feel like
juggling there's so many things leading
up to the shows
you're friends with you you're doing
dinner you're doing like pre-games well
it's like so many things happen it
happened to be social I'm like sometimes
I gotta just like I'll find a place by
myself and it's like chill for a sec
yeah but we do a lot of stuff we always
pregame yeah you just have to be
responsible sometimes because every day
like we do a lot of colleges too and
they're like oh you guys we're at like
you know they don't it's like we want to
have a good time with them you know or
have a good time at every show but it's
like body wise and health wise do you
ever like hit up the local fraternity
party after your show or sorority like
we go out with the college students yeah
I think like that's one of the things we
love to do is like actually spend time
like with the people who listen to our
music because like that's always the
best you know so like if we do a college
friend will definitely roll up to a
friend it's actually I feel like that's
more important than the actual show when
we go to college parties the pregame we
make sure to pregame an after-party with
them I feel like that's more important
than the show cuz they they appreciate
that more they're gonna remember that
you know like I mean they'll remember
the show but like don't remember us
partying with them beforehand like that
means a lot I feel like and we make an
effort to do that it like every show is
so that's so fun I remember I went to
Colgate and we said like have a lot of
backs come and they would like some of
them would come out after was really fun
yes you are making an impact I'm gonna
take one more question if you guys
weren't making music what would you be
doing yeah I mean when we first met we
had day jobs like I was doing working
radio yeah but doing the sales side of
it I was so miserable so like I don't
really know where I'd be if we weren't
doing this together yeah for me I mean
I've always known I went to make music
since I've been playing music since I
was like eight years old I went to
school for music like I've I've been a
one-track mind
whole life like I don't know what else
there's no other plant being like this
is I've had all my eggs in like this
basket it's just been like okay little
side job here a little side job here to
keep going towards like what it what the
ultimate goal is but I don't know what
else side to be doing this is like we
have everything all the chips yeah
everything's in one that's great well
we're so glad it's working we're
enjoying it thank you so much for
joining us where can everyone follow you
we are lost kings on everything yep
perfect everyone take a listen this is
really great stuff really great stuff uh
have a safe travels home thank you
everyone else we will see you tomorrow
hopeful Katia is better if not stay
tuned for what we do
you